given the semantics of the real world
and the messiness of that what does the
word correctness mean when you're
talking about code
there's a lot of dimensions to
correctness
historically and this is one of the
reasons i say that we're coming to the
end of the era of software
because for the last 40 years or so
software correctness was really defined
about functional correctness i write a
function it's got some inputs does it
produce the right outputs if so then i
can turn it on hook it up to the live
database and it goes
and more and more now we have what i
mean in fact i think the bright line in
the sam between machine learning systems
or modern data driven systems versus
software classical software systems
is that the values of the input
actually
have to be considered with the function
together to say this whole thing is
correct or not and usually there's a
performance sla as well like did it
actually finish making sla sorry service
level agreement so it has to return
within some time you have a 10
millisecond time budget to return a
prediction of this level of accuracy
right um so these are things that were
not traditionally in most business
computing systems for last 20 years at
all people didn't think about it
but now we have value dependence on
functional correctness so that that
question of correctness is becoming a
bigger and bigger question what does
that map to the end of software
we've thought about software as just
this thing that you can do in isolation
with some you know test trial inputs and
in a very you know um
very sort of sandboxed environment and
we can quantify how does it scale how
does it you know perform how many nodes
do we need to allocate if we want to
scale this many inputs
when we start turning this stuff into
prediction systems real cybernetic
systems you're going to find scenarios
where you get inputs that you don't want
to spend a little more time thinking
about you're going to find inputs that
are not it's not clear what you should
do right so then the software has a
varying amount of run time
and correctness with regard to input and
that is a different kind of system
altogether now it's a full on cybernetic
system it's a next generation
information system that is not like
traditional software systems can you
maybe describe what is a cybernetic
system do you include humans in that
picture so is it as a human in the loop
kind of complex mess of the whole kind
of interactivity of software with the
real world or is it something more
concrete well when i say cybernetic i
really do mean that the software itself
is closing the observe orient decide act
loop by itself so humans being out of
the loop is is the fact what
for me uh makes it a cybernetic system
and humans are out of that loop when
humans are out of the loop when the
machine is actually sort of deciding on
its own what it should do next to get
more information
that makes it a cybernetic system so
we're just at the dawn of this right i
think everyone talking about mlai it's
it's it's great but really the thing we
should be talking about is when we
really enter the cybernetic era
and all of the questions of ethics and
governance and all correctness and all
these things they really are the most
important questions okay can we just
linger on this what does it mean for the
human to be out of the loop in a
cybernetic system because isn't the
cybernetic system that's ultimately
accomplished in some kind of purpose
that
at the at the bottom
you know the turtles all the way down at
the bottom turtle is a human
well the human may have set some
criteria but the human wasn't precise so
for instance i just read the other day
that um earlier this year or maybe it
was last year at some point the um
libyan army i think
sent out some automated killer drones
with explosives
and there was no human in the loop at
that point they basically put them in a
geofenced area said find any moving
target like a truck or vehicle it looks
like this and boom
um
that's not a human in the loop right
so increasingly the less human there is
in the loop the more concerned you are
about these kinds of systems because uh
there's unintended consequences like
less
the original designer and engineer of
the system is able to predict
uh even one with good intent is able to
predict the consequences of such a
system is that that's right there are
some software systems right that run
without humans in the loop that are
quite complex and that's like the
electronic markets and we get flash
crashes all the time we get um you know
in the in the heyday of high frequency
trading there's a lot of market
microstructure people doing all sorts of
weird stuff
that the market designers had never
really thought about contemplated or
intended so when we run these full-on
systems with these automated trading
bots um
now they become automated you know
killer drones and then all sorts of
other stuff we we are that's what i mean
by we're at the dawn of the cybernetic
era and the end of the era of just pure
software
are you more concerned
if you're thinking about cybernetic
systems or even like self-replicating
systems so systems that aren't just
doing a particular task but are able to
sort of multiply and scale in some
dimension
in the digital or
even the physical world are you more
concerned about uh
like the lobster being boiled so a
gradual with us not noticing
um
collapse of civilization or
a big explosion
uh like oops
kind of a big thing where everyone
notices but it's too late
i think that
it will be a different experience for
different people
um i do i do um share a common point of
view with some of the climate um
you know people who are concerned about
climate change and and just the
uh this uh
the the big existential risks that we
have but unlike a lot of people who are
who share my level of concern i think
the collapse will not be
quite so dramatic as some of them think
and what i mean is that i think that for
certain tiers of let's say economic
class or certain locations in the world
people will experience dramatic collapse
scenarios but for a lot of people
especially in the developed world
the um realities of collapse will be
managed there will be narrative
management around it so that they
essentially insulate the middle class
will be used to insulate the upper class
from
the pitch forks and the and the um
flaming torches and everything it's
interesting because uh so my specific
question wasn't as generous my question
was more about cybernetic systems or
software okay uh it's interesting but it
would nevertheless perhaps be about
class so the effect of algorithms might
affect certain classes more than others
absolutely i was more thinking about
whether it's social media algorithms or
actual robots
is there going to be a gradual effect on
us where we wake up
one day and don't recognize the humans
we are or or is it something truly
dramatic where there's you know like
a meltdown of a nuclear reactor kind of
thing chernobyl like catastrophic events
that
are almost bugs in a program that scaled
itself too quickly yeah i'm not as
concerned about the visible stuff
and the reason is because the big
visible explosions i mean this is
something i said about social media is
that you know at least with nuclear
weapons when a newt goes off you can see
it and you're like well that's really
wow that's kind of bad right i mean
oppenheimer was reciting the baha'i gita
right when he saw one of those things go
off so
we can see nukes are really bad he's not
reciting anything about twitter
well but right but then when when you
have social media when you have um uh
all these different things that conspire
to create a layer of virtual experience
for people that alienates them from you
know reality and from each other that's
very pernicious it's impossible to see
right and it kind of slowly gets in
there
you